pas de menhirs landes comme disent ses
opposants à carnac en tout cas pas dans
l'immédiat le ministre de la culture
jean-jacques aillagon a enterré le
projet d'aménagement des alignements des
fameux menhir projet qui prévoyait
notamment l'expropriation de riverains
laurence de recherche les plus anciens
menhirs ont survécu huit millénaire lui
aura quand même exister 11 ans le projet
d'aménagement du site de karnak qui
rassemble plus de 6000 menhirs et autres
domaines est aujourd'hui abandonné un
projet contesté baptisé men irlande par
les défenseurs de l'environnement et par
les partisans de l'identité bretonne
même chez les touristes la nouvelle est
un soulagement c'est commercial series
nature je crois que les gens d'ici du
coin les gens du coin donc préfère ça un
projet enterré dans sa version actuelle
mais pas complètement abandonné le
ministre de la culture est venu lui même
se rendre compte et a jugé la copie à
revoir
terminées les boutiques à profusion sur
1600 mètres carrés terminer la grande
cafétéria et la route a dévié et plus
question surtout d'expropriation
mais très contente de cette décision que
le ministre de la culture après on était
quand même expropriés et pour nous c'est
un grand soulagement
plus mesuré plus discret surtout plus
respectueux de l'environnement
le nouveau projet devra être élaboré
cette fois avec les associations locales
et surtout par toutatis avec la vie des
carnacois